a short time ago and a lab not so far
away
welcome to the Shiki science show Wow in
this video video number 60 we're gonna
talk about the force awakens
McKenney protection that and really
annoyed me the force had reached the
cells
how will the genome be protected
can the Shiki science show you explain
how the cells should respond find out in
this video that entry would have been
much better if I actually had the Star
Wars music playing on the backgrounds
but for now let's just move on in this
video we're going to talk about how
cells respond to forces in particular
mechanical stresses but also why they
respond to these stresses and then we're
going to focus on the short term and
long term consequences that was recently
described in a cell paper so much like
how we respond to our external
environment such as in this analogy here
where I'm getting squashed by over a
sponge or some concrete the latter of
which I'm not very happy about cells
also respond to their environments and
one way they respond is through a
process known as Makani transduction so
I introduced the concept of Makani
transduction in my last video but to
describe is again Makani transduction
refers to the conversion of mechanical
signal from the extracellular
environment of the cell into a
biochemical signaling pathway that
enables a cell to respond adaptively to
its environment so I may have already
given away the answer but why do cells
respond to force well firstly it's
adaptive for a cell to be able to do
this and as well learn later in this
video they do this response to help to
protect their genome but also it helps
them to also their gene expression
accordingly and respond in the best
manner to the force but it's also seen
in developmental processes because
certain forces can also induce cell
differentiation and it's also involved
in performing cellular processes
themselves such as mitosis which is when
the cell divides say cells have to be
able to respond to different types of
forces and one type before
is when as I was stretched and this was
investigated in this recent cell paper
heterochromatin driven nuclear softening
protects the G name against mechanical
stress induced damage so stretching a
cell was pretty stressful for a cell yes
its DNA is critical for its performance
so this paper looks into mechanisms that
actually help protect the DNA from
getting damaged so what did they
discover well before I explain that we
first needs to make sure that we're all
on the same page in terms of some
college school terms so I've drawn out
here s au and the nucleus which is what
contains the DNA but this DNA is often
referred to as chromosome because DNA is
actually wrapped around a set of
proteins called histones because fun
fact the DNA is around 2 meters in
length yes if it's a tiny little nucleus
how does it do that so DNA is negatively
charged which me to be trying to squash
it together it's going to repel each
other
so what it does instead is it wraps
around these these proteins known as
histones which have a positive charge
and so this helps to facilitate the
compaction of DNA and I'm going to thank
my prove yourself for generating these
lovely hand-drawn sketches on my blog so
you can see the different layer levels
of DNA compaction so what we're mostly
interested in for this video is these
histone proteins that are joining green
and so these histone proteins can be
modified and accumulate sacred marks and
one of these marks is a methylation on
h3k9 which if that makes no sense
it doesn't matter that's just a specific
mark that could be added to histones
when this mark is present is associated
with the chromatin being more compacted
the other really key bits of information
he needs before I explain data is that
there's an organelle within the cell so
an organelle is a sleek white house
but the nucleus for example is an O
canal but that's not another organelle
referred to as the endoplasmic reticulum
and the membrane of this organelle is
continuous with the outer membrane of
the nucleus this will be important for
later on but for now it's important to
know that the nucleus is actually really
important for facilitating McKenry
transduction so now we are ready to look
at this paper so what I said so far is
that what they did in this paper is look
what happens when you stretch themselves
and a crude summary of what they saw is
that they saw two distinct mechanisms of
Makani protection which is protection of
the DNA from damaged one of these was at
a rapid response level a more modern
more long-term response so what does
they do
and what were these responses so if you
have a 2d culture of cells you can
either stretch cells in one direction or
two directions ever uniaxial biaxial
they change the units you'll approach in
the study and then you can often also
vary how much you stress ourselves by
and David there's over a five percent
stretch or a forty percent stretch it
turns out that the amount of stretch is
also important for the response so
following from now I'll only describe
what they saw at the 40 percent stretch
and so they saw short-term and long-term
responses so short time referring to 30
minutes after stretching and long time
being 360 minutes after stretching and
so they began with a monolayer of cells
and if you stretch them for 360 minutes
you'll see that sells brie orientates
such that they align perpendicular to
the directional stretch this
perpendicular orientation has been seen
before and the reason behind this is
thoughts be g2 strain avoidance so by
aligning perpendicular to the stretch
they can help preserve the nuclear
structure and integrity but what was
most interesting about this study was
the short term responses that they saw
and these rapid responses were seen at
the chromatin level so what is it
cramsey look like before stretch so one
common observation of cell nuclei is
that these modifications these h3k9
methylation marks often seen at
chromatin near the nuclear envelope and
this nuclear envelope is also associated
with the presence of the lamin proteins
that reside just underneath the nuclear
envelope but interestingly 30 minutes
into the stretching one may saw that the
nucleus started to wrinkle and they also
saw that there was a decrease in their
levels of this modification mark and say
he didn't see the marks around the
nuclear envelope so why does this matter
well I told you before that these marks
are associated with more compact
chromatin say the result of reducing the
levels of this mark is that you have a
reduce nuclear stiffness and the
associated increase florida fication
my new favorite word's helps to
dissipate stress and prevents damage to
the nucleus itself so how this is
achieved and why does it happen when the
cells get stretched well now we need to
use our bit of knowledge about the
organelle the endoplasmic reticulum and
the membrane of this organelle has
channels without you as P at c1 and when
the membrane gets stretched due to cell
stretching this this membrane child the
PSA one can get opened and what does
this channel does it allows the excess
of calcium ions from the endoplasmic
reticulum into the cytoplasm and say
what they observed in asani was an
increase in the calcium levels in the
cytoplasm the precise mechanism by which
an increased calcium levels can result
in the decrease and these modification
marks it's not exactly known but that's
partly due to the fact that calcium
signaling is very complex and play a
terrific but the interesting thing about
this study is that when he examines the
chromosome at 360 minutes they saw that
it had actually your thoughts said back
to the state that it was before cell
stretching and so at 360 minutes this is
all
so the time period and they sold the
reorientation of the cells and this was
as we said earlier to help prevent and
authority to the strain that's caused by
stretching so the question is why why do
you lose and refer back to the original
chromatin states well at the end of the
day the most critical thing is that the
DNA can prevent mutations and disruption
but also the chromatin structure itself
is also really important for determining
which genes are expressed and won so
preserving that structure is also really
important so by going back to the
original States allows the cells to
preserve that chromatin structure and
retain their self-identity so I have
only briefly touched on the results that
they saw in this paper and see if you
are interested in more about it you
should definitely check the paper out
because it's a really good read but to
summarize what I've explained so far
they saw two main mechanisms of Makani
protection she prevents DNA damage one
of these was a rapid chromatin response
and this is when we sought the reduction
in the h3k9 methylation mark they're
moving the nucleus more fluid and helped
to dissipate stress that is caused from
stretching and then the second made of
McCamey protection was on a slower time
scale and that was that the super
cellular levels in the tissue level and
what they saw was the South aligned in a
manner perpendicular to the stretch that
enabled them to avoid the strain and
this meant that the nuclear was also
preserved but because of this so also
meant that the chromatin structure could
also also refer back to its original
state because effectively wasn't needed
anymore right it caused the protection
from the super cellular level that the
individual cell responds and the
chromatin level was and very no longer
needed so these results add a new
function to chromatin as being the
savior of nuclear damage and generally I
think those people is pretty cool and
also there's still gaps to fill but it's
still pretty interesting and I like the
phrase mechanic
so may the force be with you and as
always thanks listening